et si ce soir on parlait de résilience
bonsoir à tous je suis grégory
m j'ai 30 ans et je suis ce qu'on
pourrait appeler un entrepreneur qui a
échoué à l'âge de 27 ans qui est un peu
plus de deux ans alors que j'avais tout
pour réussir une start up innovantes qui
disputait son secteur une centaine de
collaborateurs de collaborateurs un
chiffre d'affaires en forte croissance
j'ai brutalement échoué et mon rêve a
été brisé avec tous les soucis qui vont
avec un redressement judiciaire je
voudrais qu'on parle ce soir ensemble de
cette notion de ce concept de la
résilience après l'échec et ce qui est
intéressant dans ce témoignage c'est que
je n'ai pas rebondi et je suis en plein
dedans dans cette résilience
qu'est ce que la résilience une personne
résiliente
c'est une personne qui après un
traumatisme après un échec va avoir une
capacité à rebondir une capacité à se
projeter dans de nouveaux projets avec
optimisme malgré l'adversité de ce qu'il
est en train de traverser
est ce qu'on appelle un traumatisme
c'est un événement brutal qui va
remettre en question des choses qu'ils
ne l'ont jamais été auparavant
alors on peut se poser une question est
ce que la résilience est inné est-ce
qu'on est avec bien évidemment qu'il ya
des personnes qui vont avoir des
facilités dû à leur éducation voir leur
surtout leur personnalité à être
résiliente face à un traumatisme mais si
je suis ici ce soir c'est que je pense
vraiment qu'il y a une méthode pour
devenir résilient après un traumatisme
et c'est ce que je suis venu vous
partagez donc cette méthode pour cette
recette l a4 agréé dian le premier
ingrédient c'est savoir récupérer après
l'échec donc souvent après un échec
on va être dans une phase de déni n'a ni
envie d'écouter le pourquoi ni envie
d'en parler
et donc il faut savoir récupérer au sens
propre du terme
psychologiquement et physiquement mais
c'est pas ça dont il s'agit
je vous parle de savoir récupérer dans
la vie courante au quotidien parce que
ce traumatisme cet échec il est là tous
les jours il va pas s'en aller il va
faire partie de vous il va faire partie
de votre histoire et donc il faut savoir
récupérer au quotidien et donc pour
récupérer il faut mettre en oeuvre des
activités
quelle qu'elle soit qui vont pouvoir
vous permettre d'être dans un moment
ponctuelle de la journée 100% concentré
sur ce que vous faites vous pensé ni au
passé ni au futur vous êtes concentré et
vous allez voir que cette activité là
elle va vous permettre de prendre du
plaisir et pour la première fois après
l'échec de profiter du moment présent et
en fait vous allez construire à porter
des sources de bonheur ponctuelles dans
votre quotidien qui vont vous donner une
petite motivation le matin pour vous
lever c'est quand même le traumatise ils
restent là et ça ces petites activités
ces petites sources de bonheur
ponctuelle elles vont vous permettre de
récupérer au jour le jour et de
décompresser d'oublier finalement petit
à petit ce traumatisme ou plutôt
d'apprendre à vivre avec ce avoir
récupéré le deuxième ingrédient c'est
comprendre le pourquoi
pourquoi on a échoué tirer les
enseignements de cet échec est bien
évidemment qu'on va tous avoir le
réflexe qu'on va se sentir prêt de va
avoir une réflexion très personnel sur
pourquoi on a échoué
moi ce que je vous conseille c'est de
prendre du feedback
le premier avantage de prendre du
feedback c'est que pour la première fois
après l'échec
vous allez vous mettre dans une posture
d'écouté vous allez être prêt à entendre
des choses et quand vous avez du
feedback avec votre interlocuteur
il va vous évoquez enfin il va vous
il va aborder sa perception des faits
sans jugement et dans ce qui va être
intéressant c'est d'échanger avec lui et
peut-être qu'en échangeant avec lui vous
allez avoir des réponses à des
questionnements ou peut-être même qu'il
va évoquer des choses auxquelles vous
n'auriez pas pensé seul et donc vous
allez avec cette démarche contre
construire ou plutôt comprendre le
pourquoi
le résultat de cette réflexion
il doit aboutir à une conclusion c'est
je suis responsable de mon échec
vous devez suffisamment vous remettre en
question pour admettre que ne sont pas
les autres responsables c'est vous
uniquement qui est responsable
et comme rien n'est impossible
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle vous
allez pouvoir capitaliser sur cet échec
ne plus jamais reproduire ses erreurs et
vous allez vous sentir prêt à un nouveau
projet un projet voire même plus
ambitieux vous allez reprendre confiance
comprendre le pourquoi troisième
ingrédient on va dire que c'est le
moteur pour de la résilience c'est
l'élément incontournable incontournable
pardon c'est votre raison d'être
comment vous voulez rebondir si vous
savez si vous savez pas où vous allez
une personne non résiliente
elle va avoir comme réaction après un
échec mais comment je vais faire pour me
sortir de tous mes problèmes
une personnes non résidentes une
personne résidant résiliente cas une
raison d'être est clair une vision de
claire là où elle veut aller
elle va être obstiné par une seule chose
comment je vais atteindre mon rêve
comment je vais atteindre mes objectifs
ma raison d'être
alors que finalement elle est autant et
galère que la personne non violente et
ça en fait une différence fondamentale
dans la manière d'aborder les chèques
donc pour identifier sa raison d'être il
ya deux questions à se poser les
questions qui nécessitent beaucoup de
réflexion il ya qui je veux être c'était
un sujet qui a été abordé ce soir
et qu'est ce que j'ai envie d'accomplir
dans ma vie et pour accompagner cette
raison d'être mais où il va vous falloir
définir des valeurs et ses valeurs ce
qui est chouette avec l'échec c'est que
vous allez voir qu'elles vont se
préciser
grâce à cet échec et elles vont vous
permettre lorsque vous allez avancé dans
votre bon de déterminer un cab pour
prendre des décisions qui vont être en
cohérence
finalement avec cette raison d'être
troisième ingrédient la raison d'être et
enfin le dernier pour être résilient il
faut avoir envie d'avancer encore on a
récupéré
quand on a compris le pourquoi et quand
on a la vision claire de là où on veut
aller
malheureusement il n'y a pas de chemin
tout tracé pour rebondir
il ya une multitude de possibilités et
donc il va vous falloir être
débrouillard improvisé saisir des
opportunités
être créatif par obligation vous battre
en clair pour résumer il va vous falloir
la démarche avoir pardon c'est apprendre
en marchant mais qui est mieux placé que
vous messieurs dames pour apprendre à
prendre en marchant vous qui avez échoué
vous qui avez compris vos erreurs et
vous qui avez des valeurs qui vous
permettent de prendre les décisions pour
avancer en marchant personnes alors
est-ce que l' envie ça suffit je pense
que la réponse est non bien évidemment
un cas le travail et la valeur du
travail qui est importante on n'a rien
sans rien et quand vous vous rebondissez
vous partez un peu plus loin que les
autres et donc il va falloir travailler
plus que les autres psychologiquement et
dans la vie de tous les jours et ce
quatre bien avait avec cette notion de
travail c'est que plus on travaille
intelligemment
plus on se rapproche du résultat
escompté et donc en travaillant
finalement vous allez reprendre
confiance en vous vous allez vous sentir
prêt à rebondir et à relever de nouveaux
défis
enfin la dernière question qu'on peut se
poser dans l' envie d'avancer
c'est ce qu'il faut avancer seul
bien évidemment que non et moyennes
phrase que j'aime beaucoup c'est seul on
va vite
ensemble on va plus loin et je peux vous
garantir pour avoir échoué qu'on veut
pas aller vite
quand on a échoué on veut aller loin
alors plus loin que la première fois et
puis loin vers sa raison d'être est donc
comme vous avez des valeurs des
croyances vous allez les partager avec
votre entourage peut-être que vous allez
rencontrer de nouvelles personnes et ces
personnes là elles vont être
facilitatrice pour votre bon que ce soit
pour vous accompagner dans le doute que
pour vous redonner confiance pour vous
ouvrir des portes
elles vont être facilitatrice et donc
elles vont donner cette capacité à
rebondir
donc en conclusion on a quatre
ingrédients savoir récupérer comprendre
le pourquoi
la raison d'être et l'envié d'avancer et
moi j'aimerais ce soir que vous puissiez
en sortant d'ici vous poser une seule
question qui est fondamentale qui a
contre-courant de l'échec mais qui va
vous permettre peut-être d'être
résilient avant un prochain traumatisme
ou un prochain échec ce que je vous
souhaite pas bien évidemment et cette
question c'est la suivante qu'est-ce qui
vous rendrait être éternellement heureux
merci
[Applaudissements]